hey guys I'm Lisa R from the score
eSports and we're at the Red Bull boot
camp in Toronto a head of CI seven and
we're going to play a very special
edition of you laughs you lose with og
are you guys excited to play you guys
already have your game based it only
starts when the video starts so you guys
can laugh now okay quick question who
laughs the easiest of the group Oh
perfect okay and who's able to keep a
straight face most of the time Oh doable
pressure on me let me tell you guys how
the game works
first off I'm going to show you guys a
video compilation of funny videos taken
from the internet anyone who laughs or
smiles loses and they will automatically
be given a typical question at the end
anyone who manages to keep a straight
face looks own cold wins and will get a
very easy question at the end it's that
simple - you guys ready to play let's do
it
[Music]
did I study the problem I mean you
already know what's coming up the
problem you have as far in the video
that bacon that's like maple play the
middle time yeah yeah so yeah I took
that out I thought yeah I know who would
like that me so I ate it oh no you keep
me thanks
use me excuse me you want to be in our
video oh okay can you do like a pose for
the video or something
so thank you all tomorrow
I'm sorry mr. Kaul um I was calling you
back to let you know that I I love you
and I miss you I really really want you
to call me back and that I I know you're
done so so when you get this can you
call me back I love you thank you I
wrote a blog so so I'll go about why you
hate video games because this is what it
does it it feels like the male fantasy
what is the og stand for huh some people
say orangutan ganja I say I don't
[__] know overrated gamer Olympic
game sometimes duck two three four shake
it
ah and ducks two three four Bama - time
to be my babies
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
but all the rules and permits bottles
and hills made it difficult for the
small farmer to do so
[Music]
it was actually easier to get you guys
laugh but I expected I blame Anna black
people oh you only want three sizes
right it started it I'm gonna hand you
the mic first your question you played
on seems too great before hey calm down
calm down calm down
what did you learn from your time on
Kings nature that you were able to apply
on this scene
well kicking players know I learned a
lot I think the main thing is that I
feel like everybody on that team was
better than me and so you just learned
from everybody not just like from one
specific person as a captain and you
learn about yourself that I wanted to
this was not a role for me so in the end
like it pushed me to become a way better
players and the captain so I learned
from everybody and nothing so with puppy
on the team as the captain at hand did
you learn something in specifics about
what it means to be a captain a good
captain I think he has very good things
about him that other people don't have
he has like a type of I guess or you can
call it the toffee or that I think is
unique to him and I don't think I'm the
same person so that's the main thing I
think he had that it's hard for other
people to replicate but I think in-game
things related I think there are a lot
of captains who can do same or better
and of course he changed as well over
time so I don't know how he is now but I
think s4 was a big shot color and secret
actually that I learned a lot from as a
captain of this team what's the one
thing that you bring or you try to do
them oh I I tried to buy all the things
so you know they can carry me and
everything they are important um no I
think I I do try to kind of lead the
game but also leave space for everybody
else to have their own ideas and
contribution and also their chance to
call in-game what they think to do is
right
so that way I hope I'm making everybody
feel like you know their opinion matters
even if it doesn't why does he make that
assumption
what we want to say something about him
being the captain it's really good see
your turn
alright you want to hand over the mics
on a now are you ready for your question
you guys have a lot of success becoming
and yet the community seems to give you
the most harshest criticism why do you
think the community dislikes you so much
oh I don't know maybe because I'm like a
new player so I didn't know what to
expect and if it's not like super good
or something like they're gonna get any
gold I don't know I don't really care I
asked me who star to everybody else and
yeah I don't really mind it it kind of
affected me before but not really
anymore
is a good time you guys read the
comments often you guys had to say awful
I did mecca's man yeah yeah I found
series what what was the most memorable
hate comment you ever got I feel we can
go around on this I'm sure what do you
think you would need to do to turn the
communities
I guess opinion on you wheel it together
I guess there you go Yeah right
although we say that change yeah I think
it has changed but I've actually you
know there's a meme going around by
[Music]
all right well hopefully
ti7 you can turn around everyone sing in
a blue bottom to direct so you've had a
history of a couple of unsuccessful
teams but you know red pandas being one
of them for anchors
I love your fish what was the worst team
you would say you played for and why
worst team where Stephen life
I think team take care up team tinker
was a very special case I think all of
us who ever play for that team which is
like 15 players or something because the
constants awful and lots of negative
comments that was the reason why he
liked that uh it'll probably it's a lot
of like I don't want to go this okay
worst teammate on this team I watch
watch this is our face it could be
anything what you guys live together
right take me anyway like who kneels my
cookies or who leaves the milk out you
know what I mean but they don't do it I
do it were skating made on the team
alright alright you want to pass pass on
on the mic stand no tail I'm ready for
this question are you think it's with
you a fanatic question hi MA see we had
a lot to choose from but we had to
narrow it down and I think we're cloud
nine I'm ready alright we were curious
you and fly forms team secret back then
and you guys were saying how looks the
values of the team was very clear focus
you want to play your autonomy no you
got to make your own decisions but then
you guys left what was the situation to
meet you guys or let's see you guys can
explain what we've okay we both got kick
oh really
replace sorry we both got what you call
it I don't know I don't know what better
way we move yeah better place
I don't know better plan of course this
is thing where puppy I'm sure he did it
but now I think puppy wanted to play
with our TV inside for a long time and
then certain things happen and like I
get it back then or TC side it look like
some of the best dota players and it was
part of us alike you break the other
team that's like your competition the
one team that's beating you in the West
eg so I mean it's a double whopper you
take on the best team and try to build
yourself stronger so I mean there's not
much to the story other than they wanted
to players that they really want to play
with oj the team that you guys imagine
when you were forming team secret
I was they that trying to get like a
harmonious team in dota is very
difficult that just because of the way
the seasons have been working like we
tried this last year didn't work out now
we're trying again this year and I mean
this year it has been a very good year
again and hopefully also the end result
is just I mean all these things that we
wanted for players their organizations
transparency these things that's great
want to move it over to s4 we kind of
touched on this before a little bit so
you were the captain on secret right and
Alliance actually as well yeah for some
part of sacred like hasn't the time but
for some reason on this team spotted the
captain what would you say our kids con
at the captain first
I'd be looking him in the eye
[Music]
cons hmm if you could leave the room
okay bond is this and then why just be
there to them and then he doesn't show
off it yeah it can be late he was the
first one out today weren't you yeah
guys are here any other cause in game it
first picked my hair off
and that's a big con and if I of my hair
mark we don't like to always focus on
the negative so what would you say are
some dispro muscles making even more
muscles you guys are on the same page
here if you doesn't on the same page
here I'll do better finish up actually
all I know I want to interject the white
when I was looking out for your profile
apparently you do
commando Krav Maga wait commend a
problem agasa like that's the one we do
naked right that was a joke that was a
joke that was a joke obviously murder if
you ever use your skills to enact your
captain you know order it doesn't go
well if we make Mesa place after damn
it's going to thinking of them as some
secret so any success a little I don't
know the moves I'm just doing that like
a backhand is it that's what it is
discipline we used to talk about it a
lot anything discipline and they brings
it out in us on us it's a good thing you
didn't think bad things about alright so
that is the game so to wrap it up you
got any final words you want to say
guess maybe heading to ti7
anything for the fans to your fan
whatever our one fan shuttle girl and
man out there madam a good luck to all
the teams coming to TI okay yeah and
thank you to the fans know there's
thanks anything to anybody coming to get
all the players coming to TI and defense
shouting you're gonna get a little bit
of this today alright thank you so much
for playing guys you're watching you
laugh you loose with og and sporty sport
yes thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]